[Music]
did you see [ __ ] aaron rodgers on
[ __ ] rogan bro
[ __ ] rogers zuckerberg alex been away
alex berenson the guy who beat twitter
like
his last three interviews have been fire
you know so
here you go joe's lobbing grenades
lately
they didn't give a [ __ ] you want to play
football take this [ __ ] thing and i
want you to do it publicly so that i can
get more money out of those other people
that are thinking about it and they're
on the fence
yeah and then we're going to virtue
signal to say look how righteous our
league is we have
somebody said that aaron rodgers in this
interview looked like a motivational
coke dealer i saw that that was very i
was like that is exactly what he looks
like
there are all the people too that are
like is you smoking weed man it's like
clearly a cigar you're like no i'm too
i'm sure aaron rodgers not asking for
that [ __ ] trouble right now no no
yeah you're right you're right i'm sure
cam newton doesn't smoke weed
95 percent they don't no no no i know i
know i know you're not
a camera that's my point though they all
smoke weed by the way yeah but they're
just looking for i don't agree with you
looking for any reason any reason i bet
you joe was like yo you want to hit this
blown and he's like yeah regular cigars
and joe's like oh yeah of course yeah
i'll take one of these i'll sip a little
whiskey and have a cigar i can't get
suspended for that and then he's like
are we on are we on aaron joe's like no
he goes you got any coke
because that'll be gone that'll be gone
and that'll be on like in three days
yeah man i used to [ __ ] hurt i
learned how to do it on a napkin
nobody'll notice and then joe goes no
man sorry i don't have any cookies
that's okay of course i have some do you
want something
i just wanted to i asked no i didn't
even ask if you i just was asking if you
wanted something
well rogan's director
take a point okay let's see
compliance yes with the vaccine
compliance and if you don't we're going
to send a stooge to your team to show
you graphs of
your vaccination percentage of your team
compared to the rest of the league which
actually happened really yeah what was
the stooge like
oh i mopped the floor with them did you
yeah see again that's why people like no
one knew your vaccination status you
lied to your teammates no no day three
of training camp they sent the stooge in
and and he showed these slides about
what's your vaccination percentage was
in your team where you compare the rest
of the league
and i started asking them questions
about liability
well i'm not a lawyer okay cool but
you're in here talking about
all these different
things and you don't talk about
anybody's personal health issues there's
zero exemptions you took out religious
exemptions you took you took out
peg exemptions you took out
anybody's ability to
have an opinion no i don't want to do
this
well it's not only going to affect your
uh day-to-day status on the team but
your ability to get a job your ability
to keep a job your ability to get a try
out if you get cut from this team
because you want to put a percentage
above 90 percent of your team where you
guys can have some sort of like special
virtue like look how amazing we are
we're above the now this is a really
good point he was pointing out it's not
because he there's who goes more into it
later but it's not really about guys
like kim he's aaron rodgers he's going
to play no matter what he's a [ __ ]
one of the best quarterbacks ever play
the game right
but what he's saying is the issue is now
the team is cutting players that are
good enough to be on there but if
they're unvaccinated they want to hit
that 90 percent vaccination rate for the
team right
so they'll just cut someone that's good
you know that had potential only because
he was unvaccinated just to get the
number up ninety percent
height controlled here and then and then
they scared teams and said if you had an
outbreak caused by a non-vaccinated
player you'd not only forfeit that game
if you had enough players out but you
wouldn't get paid for that week
and here i am showing up to training
camp joe the first day and we got five
people who work for the organization
out with covid all fully vexed
and i got covered from a
fully vaxxed individual who only got
vaxxed to keep his potential
of being a part of the nfl can i say
this is a great point about something
same player in here
if it's an unvaccinated player that
causes an outbreak you have to forfeit
that game and you had to
you didn't get paid that no one got paid
that for that week in the nfl and then
your team
but if a vaccinated player
got somebody
caused a covet outbreak you did not have
to forfeit the game and you got paid for
the week what his point is
a vaccinated player
gave him an unvaccinated person covid
right well that's different you're
unvaccinated that's why you got it well
you see what i mean it's like but then
if he even though he was he wasn't the
guy that started if then if he in turn
got somebody else if somebody else cover
that is vaccinated
then he has to they the whole thing
the guy who ruined the packers exactly
bro they [ __ ] this culvert thing up so
hard it's coming out man it's weird
oh it's all coming out now yeah
yeah it it i will it's it's [ __ ]
super odd let me see because i also had
one more
a couple more rogan things because like
you mentioned before rogan's just been
on a [ __ ] tear with the interviews
lately
uh
and i thought this was interesting
because this is a complete change in
stance for him
no one who is alive today had ever
experienced a true pandemic
and i'm hoping that now that this is
over people are going to
you know recognize that some serious
errors were made and not repeat those
that's the best you can get out of it so
what do you tell those people vote
republican
jesus
i mean i don't know how
serious he's being but well let's see
let's see let's have a little bit
afterwards let's see
no hold on you want to know why he's
serious
i want merch i think i know exactly what
i could turn okay real quick
i want you to look at his face here i'll
full screen it i just want you to look
at the smirk that's the best you can get
out of it so what do you tell those
people vote republican
did you see the yeah you saw you saw the
little um the little eyebrow thing
okay
and aaron rodgers already votes
republican anyway
oh my god you're right they're not gonna
they're not gonna say they're joking
that's what a lot of them are gonna do
anyway yeah yeah oh yeah i mean more
than a million people transferred over
to the republican party
uh i think in 2021 alone find out what
that number is
but you know you look at guys like ron
desantis who kept florida open and had
some pretty reasonable policies in terms
of like what what to do about covet and
you know he mapped it out on television
he was are we getting him
i'm worried oh widely criticized for
that no are we going to get disanthers
on joe rogan
i think you'll have desantis on
because desantis isn't trump
desantis is not
he's he's trump
he doesn't have the trump baggage is put
with you that way right
i really feel like we might end up
seeing that as we get close to the
general
this
where he was saying like right because
he's had he's had bernie on you know
what i mean you'll have politicians on
we need to protect our elders we need to
you know make sure that medical care is
available for those people and everyone
else you should be able to do whatever
you want to do protect your freedom
hey joe
i get it
but keep that [ __ ] in austin you hear me
i know how cool our governor is and
everything and where the cool who are
the cool kids now and stuff whatever
i get it stay in austin we're done
you love your little tesla plant there
just go stay there i i mean and listen
let me be honest with you we have
criticized rogan i think rightfully so
many times that being said
i also like to think we're always pretty
fair when he does something that's you
know honest like i don't think rogan
like a lot of people i don't i don't
think rogan is inherently evil right
like some other people you know what i
mean
i really do think that sometimes he's
misguided i do think that rogan many
times will kind of like you know
take whatever shape the person in the
room is you know you know what i mean of
course like but you know that happens
but i
do think that you got to give the guy
credit for having people on that nobody
would have on like just alex jones like
that that alone to me is like you had
alex jones on after the sandy like he
doesn't care you know